FOR -- I CAN'T EVEN BELIEVE THI.
>> BUT FIRST, AS FOX NEWS
CAMERAS CAPTURE DOZENS OF PEOPLE
AS THEY TRY TO CROSS OUR BORDER
ILLEGALLY INTO TEXAS, ONE
SMUGGLER TELLS US THE BORDER IS
OPEN FOR BUSINESS.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
>> SMUGGLERS, MIGRANTS AND MANY
REPUBLICAN LAWMAKERS SAY THE
BORDER IS OPEN, BUT HOMELAND
SECURITY SECRETARY ALEJANDRO
MAYORKAS SAYS THE BORDER IS
CLOSED AND SECURE.
AND IN A NEW INTERVIEW WITH THE
"DALLAS MORNING NEWS", SECRETARY
MAYORKAS SAYS, QUOTE, THE
POLITICAL CRY THAT THE BORDER IS
OPEN IS MUSIC TO THE SMUGGLERS'
EARS BECAUSE THEY TAKE THAT
POLITICAL RHETORIC AND MARKET
IT.
BUT IT SEEMS VOTERS TRUST
REPUBLICANS MORE THAN DEMOCRATS
TO HANDLE THE BORDER.
A NEW FOX NEWS POLL OUT THIS
MORNING SHOW IT IS THE GOP HAS A
21-POINT LEAD OVER DEMS ON THE
ISSUE, AND MANY REPUBLICANS IN
CONGRESS ARE DEMANDING THAT
MAYORKAS RESIGN AFTER E-MAILS
REVEALED THE HOMELAND SECURITY
SECRETARY KNEW THERE WAS NO
EVIDENCE BORDER AGENTS WHIPPED
HAITIAN MIGRANTS AND THEN HOURS
LATER SAID THE OPPOSITE AT A
NEWS CONFERENCE.
I WANT TO GET INTO THE DETAILS
HERE, BECAUSE THERE'S THIS
LETTER THAT WAS OBTAINED BY THE
HERITAGE FOUNDATION, AND IT WAS
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY ASSISTANT SECRETARY FOR
PUBLIC AFFAIRS TO SECRETARY
MAYORKAS.
AND IT READS, QUOTE: THE
PHOTOGRAPHER BEHIND THESE IMAGES
DEPICTING BORDER PATROL AGENTS
ON HORSEBACK TOLD KTSM THINGS
ARE NOT EXACTLY WHAT THEY SEEM.
THE PHOTOGRAPHER SAID HE AND HIS
COLLEAGUES NEVER SAW AGENTS
WHIPPING ANYONE.
SO THE HOMELAND -- SO MAYORKAS
SEIZE -- SEES THIS E-MAIL, AND
THEN AFTER THAT E-MAIL SAYS
THIS:
>> OUR ENTIRE NATION SAW
HORRIFYING IMAGES THAT DO NOT
REFLECT WHO WE ARE.
WE KNOW THAT THOSE IMAGES
PAINFULLY CONJURE UP THE WORSE
ELEMENTS OF OUR NATION'S ONGOING
BATTLE AGAINST SYSTEMIC RACISM.
>> TYRUS, I'M GOING TO GO YOU
FIRST ON ONE.
>> OKAY.
I ASKED FOR THIS STORY FOR A LOT
OF REASONS.
FIRST OF ALL, MAYORKAS IS NOT AN
HONORABLE MAN, AND HE SHOULD BE
FIRED.
HE REPRESENTS THE WORST AND
WHENEVER YOU SEE ANYONE WHO
REPRESENTS THAT IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT OR SECURITY.
HE WAS -- THE PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT AT THE TIME OF THIS WAS
SIMPLE, IT WAS TO DEFRAUD AND
BRING DOWN LAW ENFORCEMENT, AND
THEY GOT WHAT THEY THOUGHT WAS A
JEWEL, A GEM.
THEY COULD SHOW A PICTURE
DETICKETING LAW ENFORCEMENT
WHIPPING PEOPLE.
BLACK PEOPLE.
SO IT WOULD SEND RIPPLES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
HE WAS GIVEN THE INFORMATION
MOWING THAT THEY DID NOT DO
THESE THINGS, BUT THAT WAS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN THE INTEGRITY OF
NOT JUST THE FOUR INDIVIDUALS ON
THOSE HORSES, BUT EVERYONE WHO
SERVES ON THAT BORDER, EVERY LAW
ENFORCEMENT BECAUSE IT GETS --
IT'S COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
SEE, I TOLD YOU THAT'S WHAT COPS
DO.
IT GOES ACROSS -- PEOPLE DON'T
BOTHER TO GO, WELL, THAT'S
BORDER PATROL.
THAT'S POLICE OFFICERS.
HE PUT THEIR FAMILIES IN DANGER,
HE PUT THEM IN DANGER.
WHEN SOMEONE IS ACCUSED OF
SOMETHING THEY DIDN'T DO AND
THEY HAVE THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE MAN WHO'S
SUPPOSED TO BE LOOKING OUT FOR
THEM BASICALLY SAYING THEY'RE
PART OF THIS HORRIBLE SYSTEMIC
RACISM WITH NO -- WHEN THEY KNEW
DAMN WELL THAT IT WAS NOT
HAPPENING, IT WAS NOTHING LIKE
THAT, THIS MAN SHOULD HAVE BEEN
FIRED.
BUT I GET IT, HE'S NOT GOING TO
GET FIRED, BECAUSE OUR OWN
PRESIDENT BACKED HIM UP.
BUT MY THING IS WHEN WE GET THE
HOUSE, WHEN WE GET THE SENATE,
THIS SHOULD BE THE FIRST ORDER
OF BUSINESS.
AND TO THOSE -- IF THERE IS A
LAWYER OUT THERE ANYWHERE,
LISTEN, I DIDN'T GO TO LAW
SCHOOL, BUT THIS SOUNDS LIKE
DEFAMATION TO THE HIGHEST LEVEL,
TO ME, SOMEONE NEEDS TO COME OUT
AND ACTUALLY SUE THIS GOVERNMENT
FOR THE WAY THEY AT LEASTED
THESE MEN AND WOMEN ON THIS
BORDER. -- THEY TREATED.
YOU WANT TO KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON
AT THE BORDER, ASK IS A
SMUGGLER.
QUOTE, IT'S WIDE OPEN.
SHAME ON MAYORKAS, SHAME ON YOU
FOR WHAT YOU DID TO THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TRYING TO TAKE OUR COUNTRY
SAFE.
>> AND, CHARLIE, YOU HAVE SAID
YOU THINK HE NEEDS TO RESIGN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND I THINK IT EVEN GOES BEYOND
THAT BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, THE
BORDER PATROL AGENTS AREN'T JUST
COPS, THEY'RE ALSO SORT OF
QUASI-MILITARY.
THEY'RE PROTECTING OUR BORDERS.
IT'S ATTACK ON COPS AND THE
MILITARY.
BUT IT GOES TO SHOW THE LEVEL,
THE DEGREE TO WHICH THESE PEOPLE
WILL POLITICIZE ANYTHING THEY
THINK THAT THEY CAN TAKE IT TO
THEIR ADVANTAGE WHETHER IT'S
BORDER SECURITY, WHETHER IT'S
THE CHILDREN AND FAMILIES THAT
ARE MAKING THIS TREK TO THE
BORDER OR WHETHER IT'S RACE
RELATIONS IN THIS COUNTRY.
THEY WILL POLITICIZE ABSOLUTELY
ANYTHING AND DIVIDE PEOPLE.
AND I THINK IT'S SO AMAZING THAT
CLIP YOU PLAYED WITH MAYORKAS
TALKING ABOUT HE'S WORRIED ABOUT
THE OPTICS AND HOW, YOU KNOW,
WHEN PEOPLE SAY THAT THE BORDER
IS OPEN, IT ENCOURAGES MORE
PEOPLE TO COME WHICH HAPPENS TO
BE TRUE.
BUT INSTEAD OF WORRYING ABOUT
THE OPTICS, WHY DON'T YOU WORRY
ABOUT THE BORDER?
FIX THE BORDER AND THE OPTICS
WILL FIX THEMSELVES.
THEY DON'T WANT TO.
THEY WANT THE POLITICAL ISSUE.
>> AND, NICOLE, THERE'S MORE TO
THIS BECAUSE BEFORE THAT LETTER,
BEFORE MAYORKAS MADE THAT
STATEMENT THE, HE CAME FORWARD
AND DEFENDED THE AGENTS AND THEN
TURNED AROUND LATER AND SAID
THIS.
>> AND THAT'S EXACTLY RIGHT.
SO WE NEED TO LAY OUT THIS
TIMELINE TO REALLY DRIVE IT HOME
SO PEOPLE UNDERSTAND WHY THIS IS
SO OUTLANDISH.
YES, INITIALLY MAYORKAS CAME OUT
AND DEFENDED THE AGENTS, AS HE
SHOULD AS PERSON WHO REPRESENTS
OUR BORDER SECURITY.
BUT THEN HE GETS THE E-MAIL
SAYING, BY THE WAY, IN THESE
PHOTOGRAPHS, THERE WAS NO
WHIPPING SCENE WHATSOEVER.
HEN PRESIDENT BIDEN CAME FORWARD
AND PUBLICLY SAID THAT THESE
PEOPLE WILL PAY.
MAYORKAS WAS STANDING THERE, AND
HE WAS SILENT.
HE SAID NOTHING.
AND HEN A FEW HOURS LATER HE
SAID THIS, WHAT WE JUST SAID, IT
HORRIFIED US ALL.
SO WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
YOU HAD PRESIDENT BIDEN COME
FORTH AND SAY SOMETHING, AND
BECAUSE OF THAT, THAT IS HOW YOU
KNOW POLITICS COMPLETELY INVADED
THIS ENTIRE SITUATION.
AND WHAT DID THEY DO?
THEY WITHHELD THE INFORMATION
FROM THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, AND
THEY DID THAT TO PUSH FORTH
THEIR SYSTEMIC RACISM THAT THEY
HAD BEEN PUSHING DOWN ALL OF
AMERICANS' THROATS BUT ALSO TO
SUPPORT THEIR IMMIGRATION OR
LACK OF IMMIGRATION EFFORTS.
I MEAN, WHAT HAVE WE SEEN AT
THIS POINT?
NOW WE HAVE SEEN MILLIONS OF
ILLEGAL MIGRANTS COMING ACROSS
THE BORDER, THEY HAVE DONE
NOTHING ABOUT IT.
AND NOW THAT IT'S AT THE TOP OF
THE BALLOT AT THE MIDTERMS,
THEY'RE SCRAMBLING.
>> RIGHT.
HE COMPLETELY PLAYED POLITICS
WITH THIS, AND WE KNOW THE
BORDER'S INSECURE BECAUSE WE
HAVE OUR PEOPLE DOWN THERE EVERY
SINGLE DAY REPORTING ON THIS.
SPEAKING OF POLITICS, NOW WE
HAVE DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE ALL OF A
SUDDEN DECIDED TO GET IN ON THE
GAME AND START TALKING ABOUT
BORDER SECURITY, RIGHT?
>> -- BACKYARD.
>> TAKE A LISTEN TO WHAT NEW
YORK'S GOVERNOR, DEMOCRAT KATHY
HOCHUL, HAD TO SAY.
>> WE REALLY ARE LOOKING FOR A
FEDERAL RESPONSE TO THIS, TO
TAKE OWNERSHIP OF A CRISIS, AND
WE'LL BE THIS TO HELP.
BUT -- THERE TO HELP.
BUT THIS BELONGS TO THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
>> AND THERE'S MORE BECAUSE
NANCY PELOSI ON WEDNESDAY JUST
SAID THIS, QUOTE: WHAT WE MUST
DO THE IN OUR COUNTRY IS TO HAVE
COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM.
WE ALL KNOW THAT WE MUST SECURE
OUR BORDER, THAT'S OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AS A COUNTRY.
TYRUS, WE ARE LESS THAN A MONTH
FROM MIDTERMS.
>> YEAH, OF COURSE, ALL OF A
SUDDEN NOW.
AND THEN YOU HAVE TO ADD THE
FOLLOW-UP QUESTION IS WHAT DOES
REFORM MEAN TO YOU OTHER THAN
JUST SOMETHING GOOD COTO SAY.
AND REAL QUICK TO GO BACK, HOW
IS THIS -- THAT WAS A HOAX BY
MAYORKAS.
HOW IS HE DID NIRCHT THAN JUSSIE
SMOLLETT?
THERE'S NO DIFFERENCE --
>> ONE AFFECTS THREE PEOPLE, AND
THE OTHER AFFECTS MILLIONS.
>> AND TO THIS THING, OF COURSE,
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
ALL OF A SUDDEN IT'S, LIKE,
REALLY?
NOW?
HOW LONG IS REFORM GOING TO
TAKE?
I'M JUST GOING TO GO OUT ON A
LIMB THAT YOU'VE GOT TO KEEP THE
HOUSE AND THEN DAY ONE OF
WINNING, KEEPING THE HOUSE,
REFORM BEGINS.
>> YEAH, BUT THEY'VE ALREADY HAD
THAT, AND WHAT HAVE THEY DONE
WITH IT?
NOTHING.
AND NOW THEY'RE HAVING TO
SCRAMBLE BECAUSE THEY'RE SEEING
RECORD NUMBER OF MIGRANTS, AND
WHAT DID BIDEN DO THIS WEEK?
HE HAS ESSENTIALLY BROUGHT BACK
THE REMAIN IN MEXICO PROGRAM
THAT WAS A TRUMP THING.
IT IS A SOFTER VERSION AND MUCH
LESS EFFECTIVE THAN THE ONE
TRUMP IMPLEMENTED.
>> AND THEY'RE MARKETING IT IN A
MUCH DIFFERENT WAY.
>> OF COURSE THEY ARE.
>> CHARLIE, WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THIS?
WE HAVE MIGRANTS COMING ACROSS,
SMUGGLERS SAYING, IT'S OPEN.
>> OH, YEAH.
THE ONLY PEOPLE WHO ARE HAVING A
GREAT ECONOMY RIGHT NOW ARE
SMUGGLERS, DRUG DEALERS AND WAR
LORDS THAT ARE MAKING MOUNTAINS
OF MONEY BRINGING PEOPLE
ILLEGALLY ACROSS THE BORDER.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST LIES, YOU
KNOW, LISTENING TO PEOPLE LIKE
KATHY HOCHUL AND NANCY PELOSI
TALK ABOUT, OH, WE JUST WANT TO
COME TO THE TABLE AND FIX THIS,
YOU KNOW, I COVER CONGRESS FOR
15 YEARS.
I COVERED IMMIGRATION FOR MOST
OF THAT TIME, AND I CAN TELL YOU
ONE THING, ONE THING YOU CAN'T
HIT REPUBLICANS FOR, YOU CAN'T
HIT REPUBLICANS FOR NOT TRYING
TO FIX THIS.
THEY TRIED TO FIX THIS, AND
EVERY TIME THEY WOULD BRING
FORTH PROPOSALS TO FIX THE
PROBLEM AT THE BORDER, THEY
WOULD GET KILL, OF COURSE, FROM
BOTH SIDES.
AND THAT IS THE BIGGEST LIE
THERE IS.
AND THE REASON REPUBLICANS WERE
NEVER ABLE TO FIX THIS PROBLEM
IS BECAUSE PEOPLE LIKE DICK
DURBIN AND NAN KEY PELOSI, CHUCK
SCHUMER, TED KENNEDY, THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO FIX THE PROBLEM
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH A GREAT
POLITICAL ISSUE FOR THEM.
THEY WANTED -- IT'S LIKING
DILLING THE GOOSE -- KILLING THE
GOOSE THAT LAYS THE GOLDEN EGG.
YOU DON'T WANT TO FIX THE
PROBLEM BECAUSE THEN THEY DON'T
HAVE THIS WEDGE ISSUE TO, AGAIN,
TO DIVIDE PEOPLE BY RACE WHICH
IS WHAT THEY WERE DOING.
THEY DIDN'T WANT TO FIX IT
BECAUSE THEY WERE MAKING.
TOO MUCH MONEY OFF OF IT, AND
THEY WERE GETTING, MAKING TOO
MUCH POLITICAL HAY OUT OF IT.
>> AND I CAN TELL YOU AS
SOMEBODY WHO'S TALKED TO
DEMOCRATIC LEADERS IN SOUTH
TEXAS, THE